[Applaudissements]
le chef conservateur en est à sa
troisième visite de la campagne au
québec mais il doit encore faire
connaissance avec l'électorat québécois
sa maîtrise plus française n'est pas le
seul défi les perceptions aussi le chef
conservateur
ici les convictions personnelles
d'indochine ne sont pas passés inaperçus
quant à leur compte le mariage est
simplement même cet ancien ministre
conservateur encore le nom de steven un
peu sur le bout de la langue
alors pour moi monsieur à monsieur
andrew scheer
on le voit maintenant de plus en plus il
est à l'aise comme je le vois ce matin
je pense que les gens vont l'apprécier
pour séduire les québécois une promesse
environnementale un crédit d'impôt à la
rénovation verte pouvant aller jusqu'à
3800 $ par année
nous avons une qui est en train de
mais au delà du contenu du programme la
notoriété du chef compte pour beaucoup
dans une élection générale
ici au saguenay-lac-saint-jean et
conservateurs misent essentiellement sur
leurs candidats vedettes comme l'ex
paralympiens philippe gagnon et l'ancien
entraîneur de hockey richard martel
lorsqu'on demande à angie aussi ses
candidats sont plus populaires que lui
mais messieurs materi est très populaire
il semble embêter tout que j'ai voyagé
au québec genre en protégeant qui m'a
pris qui veut dans les coulisses
certains conservateurs s'inquiètent du
déroulement de la campagne
on murmure sous le couvert de l'anonymat
que le chef n'est pas assez bagarreur
cet ancien stratège conservateur croit
que les débats seront l'occasion pour
lui de se démarquer par un chef
d'opposition qui qu'il soit de se
démarquer et d'être connue avant les
grands moments d'une campagne toral
quinze jours se sont déjà écoulés depuis
le début de la campagne
et jusqu'ici les intentions de vote ne
semble pas démontré un nouvel engouement
pour le parti d'un douchez au québec
le chef a encore beaucoup de travail
devant lui pour atteindre l'objectif
ambitieux qu'il s'est fixé celui de
doubler le nombre de députés
conservateurs au québec ici louis blouin
radio canada québec